there's a bomb unknown it's already
tardy going off what is going on you're
moving with me at SuperSpeed this
service stop
I can't say are you doing that thing
where you reading my mind you read my
mind aren't you baby yeah yeah I am you
should call her hair she's on a
different planet Daz so Horton but this
problem isn't gonna just go away
what is she you're not gonna know unless
you invite her
[Music]
everybody is Charlie berry doesn't look
so hot looks like he might need some
help from a couple of his speedster
friends from different earths and I
don't know why they didn't include them
in this promo because they were totally
in the episode description that Warner
Brothers released a couple weeks ago so
maybe this is just for like people who
watch TV and have no idea what's going
on just so it's a surprise when they pop
up during the episode like oh hey Barry
flash fam don't do this by yourself ask
for some help because it's a flash
family episode of course there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter just be a subscriber
leave a comment on the video what I'm
guessing is is just based on the way
they cut the promo this is the first
fifteen maybe twenty minutes of the
episode Tilbury just spirals out of
control like he feels like he's gonna
explode with grief that he can't save
everyone before Jesse quick and Jay
Garrick show up because of that Harrison
wells
Cecille scene at the end of episode 14
call her reconcile with her like
Harrison wells is on the outs with
Jessie quick she's still on earth too
with her team flash just being the flash
of that earth doing the exact same thing
the team flash on earth one is doing
just trying to keep the city safe the
whole reason he showed up at the
beginning of the season is because Jesse
quick kicked him off of her team flash
because he was being such an so
that's like just part of his background
arc it's like a DS story you have your a
story your be story your C story and
then like all the other minor little
plot threads and I'm designating
Harrison wells Jesse quick
reconciliation is sort of like a deep
plot as far as we know Jay Garrick went
back to earth three at the end of season
three he's just been doing normal flash
business that are ever since but no clue
who the meta is that's actually setting
this bomb off she sets the bomb off then
Barry tries to defuse it so it's like he
enters flash time at the very beginning
of the episode they released this
picture here where they're all sitting
in the hangar where the bomb is going
off so it looks like Barry grabs each of
them at various points to try and use
their powers to defuse the bomb before
we get to our flash family stuff because
like you see Cisco trying to vibe it it
doesn't work and it looks like he starts
to break down too so what they might be
suggesting was some of this because
Barry looks like he's slowly wearing
down like he can only do this for so
long before he runs out of energy but
Cisco also looks like he's kind of
breaking down too like he's not meant to
exist in this flash time State at
SuperSpeed for that long so maybe normal
people are even normal metas who aren't
speedsters can't stay in this state for
extended periods of time the thing now
is like you go back to episode 10 and
iris is like how am I in here with you
in Barry's like I have no idea what's
going on now it makes more sense why
they tease that concept but there's just
so much mythology going on in this
episode that they haven't explained yet
that's one of the things the TV show
hasn't spent a lot of time doing is over
explaining the mechanics of the Speed
Force I think that's mostly so they just
don't back themselves into a story
corner in future seasons if they want to
try some cool concept because they don't
mind things like Speed Force wormhole
aliens as long as they're consistent in
the way that they treat the Speed Force
you can kind of seem going through his
paces here too like he's trying to work
on his speed equations
the thing about Barry though is that he
doesn't know as much about the Speed
Force as you would think like they
haven't spent a lot of time studying his
abilities most of season one when you
had Harrison wells
eobard thawne around when they were
actually studying Barry's powers was
just to get him to be faster not to
understand the nature of the Speed Force
like it's an energy source so you would
study it like you would study any other
science phenomena but the only real
people that did that in a big way were
Tracy from last season so she'd actually
probably be pretty handy in this
situation but I'm assuming that the
actress is on another TV show I know
what a lot of people ask what happened
to her after last season I'm assuming
it's like a tom felton situation where
they just left the show I think the
writers mostly decided not to continue
using the character order they always
intended her to be like a one-off thing
but we just need to assign Speed Force
Studies to one of the other members of
team flash at some point in a future
season just a background tasks just so
we know that somebody is at least
thinking about it on a weekly basis like
oh I learned some new things about the
Speed Force this will probably come in
handy eventually eobard thawne is
actually professor zoom because he's a
professor of speed for studies which is
kind of a funny twist they have
really explain that on the TV show maybe
if we get like a reverse flash origin
story episode at some point the really
important thing about Jessie quick in
this episode too is that she's also
going to guest star on legends of
tomorrow with Wally West
I believe it's legends episode 15 it's a
Constantine episode it's called
necromancing the stone but the name
necromancy implies that they're gonna be
dealing with things that are dead or
things that they're trying to raise from
the dead I'm not really sure why people
thought that Jesse quick might be dying
in this episode I haven't seen any
evidence to support that but I think
it's because she winds up dying in the
in Justice comics in this relatively
similar explosion and then people who
watched Young Justice saw what happened
to Wally West on that TV show that was
more of like a cyclone situation where
you had three versions of the flash
running around a giant explosion to
contain it if they've already kind of
done that on the flash like when they
vented that nuclear blast onto earth 15
wait what if I create a vacuum around
them that way even if he does explode at
least we contain the blast yes yes that
could work that could container whatever
you're gonna do is I'll do it fast
follow just one above 8,000 rads
the way this bomb is crackling it almost
looks like it's got speed force energy
inside it like you know the white
lightning that saboteur had it almost
looks like that's what's going on but we
don't know what kind of nuclear bomb
this is it just sounds like it's too big
for Barry to simply just run around like
that's probably one of the first things
that he thinks about doing maybe I'll
run around it like I run around
everything
the only other really easy solution that
they could use from the comics was
during a JLA during the Wally West era
where there was this South Korean town
that was gonna explode the bomb went off
in Wally West basically ran five hundred
thousand people out of town before it
did so the bomb went off I don't think
they're gonna blow up Central City
so whatever solution Jay Garrick Jezzie
quick and Barry come up with in the
episode it's not going to involve the
bomb blowing up Central City but
remember we just learned about those
pocket dimensions maybe like the flashes
can open wormholes to throw things into
other dimensions like the Speed Force
maybe they can phase the bomb into that
pocket dimension but let me know what
what is your solution for getting rid of
this bomb based on the evidence that
we've seen so far the important thing I
think to remember is is that we're
dealing with the speed force and this is
very comic book II so whatever they do
to solve the episode if anything
terrible happens to one of the Flash's
gone is never gone but I still like I'm
not totally 100% on anybody actually
dying during this episode because they
just did that last season like there was
a whole big arc where Jay Garrick had to
just chill
inside that Speed Force prison he took
one for the team so it's not like
they're gonna bench him again after this
like I did the whole explainer about how
Mark Hamill was gonna come back to the
flash and be the trickster this season
but John Wesley Shipp was busy on a play
so he's just gonna wait till they could
do an episode together so it just
implies that we're gonna continue seeing
Jay Garrick and future seasons and we
haven't even seen coffee shop girl so
just keep your eyes peeled for her in
this last block of episodes I don't know
how many more episodes she's back for
but I know she will be coming back
before the end of the season you may
have seen the WonderCon news they
dropped this morning Marvel and DC both
announced what shows they're bringing to
WonderCon doing presentations for
there's a Krypton panel where they're
going to be dropping a new trailer
there's a Black Lightning
panel in a Lucifer panel there is a Teen
Titans go panel but I'm pretty sure most
of you hate that show so don't worry
about that the Titans TV show is still
in the middle of shooting like its sixth
or seventh episode so I don't think
they're gonna do any kind of panels or
video presentations or anything like
that till this summer at Comic Con after
they finished most of their episodes I'm
finishing my Black Lightning episode
video for this week it was actually
pretty badass I'll name the giveaway
winner when I post that in a couple
hours there's new Avengers that I'm
working on - so if I finish Black
Lightning in time then Avengers will
post tonight if not that'll just post
Thursday morning so no worries while you
wait for everything click here for last
night's Flash Easter eggs and click here
for brand new Avengers thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome see
you guys tonight